today's visual studio toolbox Aaron is
going to give us a quick overview of
github actions which are new and they're
an interesting way of doing CI CD
pipelines from within github hi welcome
to visual studio toolbox I'm your host
Robert Greene and joining me today is
Aaron Powell hey Aaron how do you thanks
for having me thanks for coming back on
the show and today we're going to talk
about github actions that's right
this is cool this is a new thing
recently introduced and something that
I've wanted to do an episode on for a
while so this is great oh I'm glad that
I'm the perfect candidate to show you
just how to get started with it so let's
review at the highest level what is a
github action the github actions is a
it's a CI CD process or a continuous
integration continuous delivery platform
similar to you might have used with
Azure pipelines or other third parties
such as Travis CI or jenkins and things
like that but this one is built directly
into github so that if you're working
with github already as part of your
toolbox we don't need to include another
third-party product whether it's as your
pipelines or something else to do
that's the ICD process that we want so
this is kind of in line with the
previous episode where we said that
inside the visual studio code you can do
your source control you can publish to
Azure without having to change context
and from all in your work environment
and so this is kind of similar you've
got your code in github you could
certainly go over to Azure DevOps and
set up your CI CD pipeline but now
you're bouncing from there over to get
hub get up actions give the ability to
do similar things in one place exactly
cool
there's also nice options yeah yeah and
there's another advanced stuff that we
can do such as tying into it other
events that might happen in github so
it's something raising an issue or
working with pool requests we can
trigger off different things to happen
okay not just deploy straight through
the production every time someone raises
a bug I don't want to do that okay cool
that's C yeah so to getting get started
we'll see there's a new tab that's
appearing in our github application so
this application is the same one you
built on the previous episode we'll have
link to that in the show notes I want to
drill down into the awesome trivia API
app exactly and if we click on this
we'll get presented with a bunch of
starter template so we've got four
github actions i say you feel doing like
no JS actions always there or do you
have to turn it on somehow so actions it
is it'll always be there on projects
that you create okay it's a feature
that's recently gone through the preview
cycle so some accounts might not have it
activated just yet okay but there it's
rolling out pretty much to everyone as
we're speaking okay got it yeah yeah and
we can say I want to start a templates
the similar there's as we find in a lot
of other platforms and things that we've
got the popular we just blew a nodejs
application or we're trying to build a
package that we're publishing to the
node package repository but then we've
got integrations with I as your web apps
or maybe we're building a Python
application a whole bunch of different
things that we might be doing in here
okay I just have a quick look at maybe
one of these we'll grab the the deploy
web app to dasha
and you can see that this is what we've
got as as a starting point it's created
a a place where a file will go
you know github repo it's a github as a
folder slash workflows and in the name
of the workflow that we want to run so a
workload is what we call a github action
it's a series of steps so it's kind of
similar to and I want to spend the whole
episode doing side by side but this is
kind of similar to Azure DevOps
you're building a Yambol pipeline yep
the pipeline is a set of actions or
tasks that take place yep and you've got
a list of them on the right and you've
got the yeah mole on the left correct
yeah so we've got the ones on the
right-hand side of the ones out of the
marketplace then we could select and add
in just like you would do with that
should DevOps and there is our yellow
file that would be created for this now
if if I was going to use this one oh
then just hit save and commit up here
and that will put it into my git repo
but I want to show you how we can build
one from scratch so we can understand a
bit more about what's happening and the
pieces that make up to get up access
file I just hit cancel here we'll drop
back and we're going to jump over to
okay now that we're in Visual Studio
code that's great oh yeah more files
like the starting point so I'm gonna do
that by creating new file and here's a
nifty little trick that I learned
recently with Visual Studio code is that
if I want to create a file in a
particular folder I can actually include
that folder path while crammed in the
file so I can do dot github slash
workflows slash and we're just yeah I'm
just call this DevOps dot yeah cool
sorry yml mm-hmm it doesn't put yml or
yeah well I just prefer one less
character well popular there and that's
we can see here in the in the the
sidebar it's created that folder
automatically just because I put in the
path and I think that's like a nifty
little trick that it took me a long time
to learn that that existed now with a
workflow we need to create a bunch of
metadata around it similar we would have
with with other yellow based ones such
as a name and what's going to make that
trigger and things like that yeah I'm
gonna copy and paste some code so we
don't have to watch me type it all out
and we can talk about what's happening
is we're doing that so here's what I've
created earlier
I'll just grab the starting bit of it as
we resume the Yammer you're using here
is pretty similar to the Yambol that
you'd use in Azure DevOps more or less
there's definitely some overlaps with it
there's some github nuances to it which
is a slightly different approach to the
way the actions work relative to the way
tasks work in you can use it as a good
starting point yeah yeah if you're
familiar with doing the all pipelines
with inside of as your pipelines you'll
see similarities and be like okay I
understand some of the terminology and
the concepts and bring it okay cool oh
so we've got a name
another thing that will appear because
we could have multiple of these we might
have some that are only happening on
pull requests so that might be just
doing it I could test or not actually
deploying anything and this is the one
that's going to pull all the way through
our production so we can name them
differently it just makes it easier when
we look at it with inside of the github
website and then we need to specify an
event that this action is going to
trigger on so I'm gonna say that this is
going to trigger on pushes to a branch
named master right now if I had multiple
branches I could specify multiple
different
I'll specify ignore branches as well so
if I had a branch they didn't want to
get built using this particular pipeline
sorry this particular workflow mm-hmm
are you doing okay now with that done we
need to start setting up the things that
are gonna actually happen cuz this is
this is useful but it's not gonna do
anything yet it's like it will tree up
it doesn't know anything this says do
something now the question is what am i
doing exactly so I'll go grab some more
of the stuff back from the one that I've
written earlier we'll just copy it all
across and we'll talk about it as we go
through our first thing is that I've got
jobs jobs the things that I'm gonna run
inside of this I can have multiple
different jobs that can either be run in
sequence or in parallel in this case
I've only got one job it's called build
but if I had maybe like a a test and I
wanted to do deployment separately or
maybe I had unit tests and integration
tests I get of a job named tests and job
name integration test and job name
deployment and I just want to keep it
simple for this this little example that
we're looking at and you can name your
jobs by that first level indent here we
see on line 9
mmm says build okay said I can name that
whatever I want I just used build
because it helps me know what it's for
and then we need to specify what kind of
agent this is going to run on or what
what is the host for this right now we
can use Windows Linux one back because
we are you building a nodejs set of
virtual functions I'm just going to use
the Ubuntu latest ok agent so a linux
agent but if you're thinking about
building an application that needed to
you might want to run tests against
multiple different ones so you could
build on linux and on windows and on
that all from the same pipeline just by
changing the runs on section of ok have
action and finally we have steps what
are we actually doing in this section
well oh sorry what actions we actually
gonna do in this workflow and we'll see
each of these steps have a name the
first one here check out so that's gonna
get our code out of our git repo and
then we specify a user's this is to use
the as your pipelines analogy the tasks
that we're going to run at this
step so this checkout action is going to
use an action that's been predefined
called checkout and the syntax for this
is a little bit different to what we
have used if we've if we've been doing
it with github action oh sorry with
Azure pipeline I've got so many DevOps
tools that I'm working with that it all
blurs into one sometimes here we
actually specify a github repo yeah or a
Monica to a github repo that is what's
existing in our marketplace so there is
actually a repo if we go to github.com
slash actions slash checkout and that's
what we're using here okay and then with
that we can specify what tag or branch
or even the char that we want to use for
that particular action to run at this
point in time now it's it's recommended
that we don't just say like latest or at
Master or some like that because every
time someone pushes an update to that
action you're gonna immediately use it
without necessarily realizing it so we
want to use something like a tag version
or maybe a sha just so that we have
confidence that our bills are repeatable
based off of something that we know has
been pinned previously mhm but we also
don't need to use a checkout action if
we had somewhere like our deploy to
production environment we're probably
not needing the source code for that we
might be just downloading assets so we
can also drop some of these as we as we
don't need them okay the next one
because this is a no J a set of azure
functions I need to install node on the
machine right and to do that I grab a
different action this one is set up node
mm-hmm because I don't know what version
no time I want or I don't know what one
the action would want to be used by the
fault we can provide parameters to it we
do that with the with part of the y ml
statement and then we can pass
parameters so no dash version is the
version of node through to use here and
then I'm just doing 12 dot X does that
impede repeatability though because you
now know that every time you run this
you might get a different version of
what's the trade-off between specifying
it and leaving it open-ended like this
well so because I want to specify it I
want to ensure that repeatability it's
always going to use the same version of
note but if maybe I was doing something
that was I was less concerned about the
underlying host changes
I wouldn't necessarily need to provide
that and we'll just pick the latest form
I would always encourage people to
specify exact versions whether it's net
Python yeah Java etc because as you said
you want repeatability you don't want
this whole it worked last week that's
one of the promises of the DevOps
practices is repeatability exactly okay
yeah
and we can even parameterize the way
that this all works so then we might
have a global environment variable that
says this is the node version to run for
the pipeline yeah stuff like that and
then we can although maybe repeatability
I mean there's also you know
predictability right because you don't
necessarily know when you deploy this if
you're deploying it to something that
that has a latest version then yes would
catch that so it's kind of a trade off
yeah exactly
all right yeah and then we do an NPM
install so we can just run a script and
just like past script or if I was on
Windows we use for the fire powershell
script or we're using cross-platform
powershell we can even do that in here
but then we pull in appropriate action
but it's got a couple built-in things
like it's got a built in shell that it
can run so we just do like an NPM
install and then things that we really
want to do is deploy our code somewhere
yes and that's where we're gonna start
working with Asia so this work load is
doing the build and the deploy in one
this is just one single step so if any
of these steps file it won't continue on
like the bri'asia
but I could but I'm kind of used to over
an azure DevOps building my CI pipeline
and then my CD pipeline this is just one
workload that goes both just in this
example I can definitely split them out
if I wanted to so I could have
completely separate workflows and
trigger a release workflow after the
build had completed or I could even have
them with inside of the same workflow
file and
to where I look like the build node
specified on line 9
I could also specify another node
somewhere which is release and have that
dependent on the successful completion
of build right but then and then we will
use assets to pass around outputs from
builds and stuff like that so yeah we
can still we can still do all that same
sort of thing here it's just to what
level of complexity you want because it
will all happen through the same series
of github actions right so yeah we're
totally Dodger we use the azure action
so there's one existing if we go giddup
TOCOM slash asha slash login and that's
our action mhm and we can see the source
code for that there as well but we're
gonna need some credentials right well
presumably well hopefully like our
github can't just go oh I'm just gonna
deploy to a random place with inside of
azure I don't need any security for that
that doesn't sound like the best way to
go about things
no you have to supply that yeah and we
probably don't want to put our
credentials directly really inside of
this file because it's going into our
repo right so for that we can use secret
variables that are defined against our
github project mm-hmm so I've already
done that because I didn't want to
publish my credentials to everyone but
I'll just show you how you would do that
if you were doing it for a project
yourself so we got to jump back to our
browser and we'll come to the settings
I'll go get our project and we'll scroll
down to secrets in the menu here and
you'll see I've got one in there called
as your credentials so you store those
in github and then it just reads from
there yeah so like you would have
variables and secret variables inside a
natural pipeline we can have those here
as well so I can hit add a new secret
give it a name give it of value and that
will all appear in there and then that
is made available to actions when they
run cool
using this Dollars and double squiggly
brackets and is that stored at the repo
level that your account level it's sort
of the repo but we thought okay so if
you've got multiple github repos you can
have different secrets across hmm and if
the for some if for some reason white
one of them compromised
you could have just those credentials
recycle decant and it doesn't mean that
you've given access to everything right
the keys of the castle yes okay cool and
the very last one that we've got here is
that we are going to deploy our agile
function right so again we're grabbing
our action and we're probably familiar
with this sort of by now and github repo
yeah I've pinned it this and the login
app in both at v1 so that's the it's a
tag that someone has put on the the
github repo and the code in there so I'm
confident that that's where that will be
and I have to provide it with a bit of
information which is the name of the
azure function that I wanted to play to
so I've already created my actual
function here yeah and if I just hit
refresh we'll see that I haven't got
anything deployed to that and now let's
commit this github action into our
repository mmm and push it up and
fingers crossed we're going to deploy
our trivia app straight from a git push
and do you do you need to specify a
trigger that this automatically runs on
check-in or is that automatic so that's
what we've done at the very top of this
file where we've got the on so that's
the view bond yeah so so on okay that's
a trigger so that's your trigger yep
yeah there's a lot of different triggers
and I will put the documentation for get
up actions in the show notes because
there are a lot of different events that
we could also tie in to things that are
happening around your repository that
are not just related to source code then
you might want to pull formed github
actions against and then you could
specify that it's not automatically
triggered right yes just manual okay
cool
all right so we'll commit this in adding
github actions I love the fact that
being familiar with how pipelines work
and as your DevOps you now know a giant
chunk of what you need to know to come
over here and use this exactly that's
pretty cool
yeah and presumably vice-versa exactly
it means that that if as a company
you've started using github a bit more
and more and you want to try out these
tools that are built-in yeah you don't
want to have to jump back or you wind up
you know your your weekend job you're
working with a buddy who's got some code
and he says oh my gosh
going on here it's like okay well yeah I
already I already know a lot about how
this works so you can just kind of slide
in why are some new stuff so I'm just
pushing up those changes to github give
that a minute while the magic of the
internet works and the files all fly up
mm-hmm there and it said that it just
wants me to also do a get fit and fetch
to make sure that I've got all updates
from the remote repository well because
I had been doing some some work on
another machine
now we come back over here github
actions oh yeah so buildin deploy yeah
that was the name that we had in our
yellow file and we'll see that it's
already happened and it was triggered on
a push now one thing that is different
to a lot of other deployment tools that
I've worked with is that this is related
to that commit so it's very easy to work
out which commit triggered it right so I
can go back and go ah if I if I did have
something fail I can have a look back
ago exactly the point in time there it
was and it's all linked all straight
from the github you I can easily jump to
think so we can see there's the the
commit ID appearing with inside of the
browser I didn't click through and I can
see ah that was the change that
hammering that triggered this particular
plug the whole history etc and you can
figure out how many check ins broke the
bills and all that yep now if I jump
over here so in the right hand sorry the
left hand side it's it's my left hand
yes everyone's left hand we can see the
name of that that job that we had
executing which is the build job out and
because it's always been running for a
few minutes while I'm talking yeah we'll
see that the steps have already happened
there's a whole bunch of green checks I
mean we can expand some of these and say
setup no that's the kind of thing you
look at the first couple times you know
you see that it's doing all the things
you'd expect it to do and then you stop
staring at it
yeah yeah okay it's given us all green
check so it means that everything must
be successful and yeah our pipeline is
all run completely so if we jump back
over to Asia we give our functions a
refresh and now it's checking because we
should have actually the
without the functions mm-hmm I'll give
it a moment fingers crossed like I said
because it's the first time we've done
deployment and my experience has always
told me that the first time you push a a
new deployment file and a new deployment
pipeline it will never work immediately
you're always retiring so I'm optimistic
yeah you have to be you have to notice
next to functions the spinning arrows
which tells you that it's not done yet
yeah that's what that's what we're
waiting for right maybe we'll give it
another very fresh hopefully it hasn't
timed out excellent yeah there we go
so there's our our functions they got
all deployed up we didn't have anything
there before we can come into here we
could grab the URL and and get the
response just the same as we did in the
previous show where we were pushing it
straight from visual shear code but very
very cool as how we can do it entirely
from github actions and now every time I
was to do an update to this I could push
a new version this workflow runs at the
poise it's all happened straight from
visual studio code and our github repo
so if you're new to DevOps and you
decide you do want your CI CD pipeline
slash workflows or whatever you want to
take advantage of this you now have
options you can do it from github you
can do it from Azure DevOps codes in the
same place you know you can kind of
choose which one you prefer if you're
already doing as your DevOps you may
decide you like this better novo or you
may decide to run some in one place some
one another it's some option exactly and
that's what it's about it's about having
options yeah make sure that you've got
the right tools to empower you to build
what you need to build right not just
well this is the only way that I can go
down the path right and it's for people
that are already in github it's nice to
be able to do it from there as opposed
to saying okay now what tool do I use to
do my CI CD I can just do it straight
from in here exactly
fantastic yeah awesome let's show you
how to set up a get up action from
scratch that was the best twenty minute
overview of github actions ever exactly
might think about doing more
deep dive on this so I'll have to think
about that yeah yeah because let us know
if that's something you'd want to see
yeah I said there's a lot more stuff we
can do with it particularly when we try
and integrate with other things that
github can do and whether you're working
with your issues or projects pull
requests and we can have all of those
things trigger off difference that's our
workflow okay cool
thanks so much for doing this thanks for
having me hope you guys enjoyed that and
we will see you next time on visual
studio toolbox see ya
[Music]